[Applaudissements]
on essaye
[Musique]
les abdos le dingue des abdos de dingue
tu veux des muscles saillants tu veux
des cuisses de nageurs des cuisses de
nageurs tu as envie d'avoir les
tablettes de chocolat devrait biceps que
les veux te pique torts en acier des
pectoraux en acier tu veux des mollets
bien galbées tu veux des quadriceps de
fou tablettes de chocolat tablettes de
chocolat tablettes de chocolat et ben
moi non
[Musique]
avec monaco en a ailleurs
toujours là qui vont toucher les
spéculateurs
d'affaires du t1
ne pas vraiment pas bien voulu sortir
ton album l'année dernière en même temps
que moi ton album car
en même temps que le fléau la mixtape là
que j'ai senti même sage s'est pas
passée je les fuis de 1 mois et demi tu
as fait fuiter l'album de partager des
liens des machins malgré ça j'ai fait de
grosses graines que toi et la jeunesse
vont mieux que le tien bekhauri je suis
plus fort que toi sur tous les plans
tous les plans
les lave linge ou plus longtemps avec al
gore
est ce que toi aussi quand tu mets des
chaussettes à laver il y en a toujours
une qui disparaît
[Musique]
marc guez
on verra
mais sur la libye 2 et on a deux greg ou
de philippe lachaux qu'on voulait et
il ya la version roumaine
se rhabiller